don't start unbelieving is greatest
eighty song ever uh all right so this is
double dipper I'm gonna apologize right
now my voice might be little hoarse I
apologize for that um but yes this is
double dipper uh and the code at the
very beginning is paper jam dipper says
and that it's more jargon so you have to
actually translate the jargon into more
jargon and is pretty funny he's better
paper jam dipper but that was horrifying
it's better for paper jam dipper this
way yeah what I kind of like is uh both
him and different number two when they
get destroyed it's like I said you're
kind of sad you can't feel bad so okay
dude I had a good run um so this is an
episode where they discover I love this
concept of a copying machine that copies
people uh and the way it's almost like
somebody so multiplicity no but not like
the fact it's done with a copying
machine I think it's really clever and
then they comes to life on the paper and
so I don't I I know it I was is that was
the first thing I said when he starts
Kravitz I kickin copy human beings I was
like dipper hops and I'm like no dude
don't do it I've seen multiplicity this
will end bad for you you'll ruin Michael
Keaton's career he'll come back with
Birdman kind of hopefully please come
back you're you're good actor you're
awesome
oh this a Birdman will tell us so they
could just replace bird with bats and
it'll tell us um so yeah so he makes a
bunch of copies of them so cuz they're
throwing this big party which leads to
one of my favorite jokes in the flyer
when it says big party kids teenagers
welcome just as free I wish I heart that
needs to be my marketing campaign I love
it free love that um and so they all get
there and different makes a bunch of
copies to try and get with Wendy is part
of the stuff uncle plan of course it
backfires is gonna be a thing isn't it
him just constantly chasing after one
day yeah I won't give anything away but
it does lie it's not terrible I just
like it's one of those cartoon trope
plots that I kind of just made
in the second season they do something
with it that you're kind of like oh good
and have the same thing with the Robby
character to just when you're like ah
geez are we really doing this it's like
okay that's that douche bag does not
deserve to have my name like it
seriously it is just the most you know
typical cliched bully third wheel yeah
like somebody like was ask you is like
is this a flawless show and I'm like no
okay there's a couple things I like they
please at the top of my list of like
just what boring K yes so boring I mean
anyone I know to me anyone that just has
a permanent like eyebrows like this in a
cartoon I'm like okay this is gonna be
the boring character and it's not like I
know people are gonna be like but he's
meant to be boring but he's missed but
yeah but you can still make that
interesting yeah you can still make it
fun
every time he pops on screen I'm just
like like Mabel's supposed to be goofy
she's supposed to be silly but it's
funny you know Robby is not fun like
there's occasionally moments where he's
just so into himself and error hey that
it is funny and I'm like if they played
that up even like found a way to make
that even fun yeah like what are you
doing the rest of the comedy ya know
they push it that one level beyond that
makes it really funny ah but now he's
just sort of the yeah we got these other
characters we like we want to work on
you're just sort of the plot device
um and so they're so different makes his
great big list and he he tries to go
through with it doesn't work turns out
naturally talking is what worked best
where's the lesson obviously and then we
also have the dance-off between Mabel
and Pacifica Northwest it's just a great
name um she comes back in a few times
which again at first it's like she was
annoying too they she's a bit better
than Robbie that they do a little bit
more with her um and they give her a
little bit more of a character as it
goes on but yeah she still it's the
bully you know it's just sort of an it's
a boy skip you find Nelson's a funny
character in the Simpson so you can have
a fun bully you know Reese from milk in
the middle is a very funny boy uh but
yeah it's like when they're just a bully
it's pretty boring but I gave you a
little
that the writer has a thing for the
goofier characters like yeah I don't
think he like that's why the show his
yes his passion is not in the bully
characters that's for damn sure
well yeah you that's a good point like
malcolm in the middle' who ever wrote
Risa's lines they had a passion because
he was hilarious um so so Mabel in her
head that's danced off as she makes new
friends these uh these two girlfriends
one has to be voiced by Rainicorn from
adventure time uh I have a check but it
has to be um it puts Forks and her
fingers improvement of human being a guy
great wild me high I was like looking at
that I'm like that's kind of also um and
they come back again yeah those are
great HSN are great examples or pretty
much side characters they're just best
friends but everytime they come in that
they're almost always funny they're
they're funny characters um so they have
this dance-off and they lose but they
have friends still and she's like oh
yeah I've come for I love the fact that
it's a good handling of a very obvious
moral yeah like I had to give it that
like I'm just like wow this wasn't such
a good show I would have sat there been
like whatever but I'm just like I love
the way they kept partying into the
night like let's keep this thing going
yeah and I like I said I like I like the
fact that they actually lose and it's
not like hey wait Pacifica ring this and
oh nobody likes her no it's like no they
they lose but it doesn't matter and
everybody loves Pacifica still yeah like
they left for her but no I love that and
I think that was just really closer to
reality let's be honest but but that is
kind of if you hate the rich bitch you
still want to party on our toys but
that's the thing that I think you know
it's gonna be like a meeting somewhere
now are like someone's gonna gift that
just like you know Eve have you hate the
rich bitch you're still gonna party on
it is that's a life that that should be
a shirt oh but but no I like the fact
that they especially for kids watching
that I think that's a good cat fail
cause like you're not always gonna win
but it's like it it's cool you look at
the bright side of it and like you found
new people to hang out with and I just I
really respect it for taking that angle
it not only does she kind of cheat to
win uh but there's no she doesn't get
her comeuppance like she still like
everybody likes her but it's like people
but Mabel also gain something so I
thought that's really cool I get a good
handling of the of an obvious moral I
think it's a good way to put yourself
like a wrestler I'm gonna pound her face
and fill it with pain um so ya know a
good episode I mean not too many secrets
in this one I was trying to look for
stuff in the background didn't really
find anything you know once in a while
you'll find stuff in the shop that's
like covered by a sheet answer oh what's
that or like but particularly in the
mate in the main shop itself there's
always like a couple things I'm like
that hasn't changed that's always here
so this show just has to be watched
twice cuz I'm not catching half the
things like oh that thing in fene five
like well but Sami bit at forty mark
that thing under the sheet that's gonna
come back later vite see that plant in
the corner keep your oh man that's kind
of the fun thing about it but this one
didn't really have them any secrets or
anything I guess I'm just trying to
enjoy the jokes like that's a problem is
like I'm literally watching this trying
to remember all the jokes that I want to
mention that I think are really funny
but there's so many good ones yeah I
forget like probably 90% of the by the
end of it it's like I can remember like
two jokes I'm like and it's not because
the jokes are bad it's because they're
so good it's just like kinda same
jealousy fantasy dude oh that was I have
the same jealousy fantasy I love it when
he's getting his face but he said guys
guys it's me cuz it was nonsense eh when
you've got twenty copies you found in
your face guys it's me it's something
else and we nose too when I first saw us
I saw a smaller TV watching us on the
bigger one ah the other dippers are a
little faded which I thought was clad
thought I was awesome but very slightly
it's hard to pick up if you're not
watching it ah bigger TV um so get a
bigger TV and I think the other thing is
cuz we're doing this we did the first
one six yeah this is seven yeah so we
did those all in the world now we're
about what two weeks later a week later
something like that yeah yeah it's like
the day before Thanksgiving he's got a
cold
and so we put it on and and once again
I'm just like there's dipper like okay
yeah I in the groove sucka detox I'm
like oh
I keep forgetting I'm gonna have to go
through this all over honestly I think
the goodness is that voice I think it's
a good episode get used to that voice
though because I think he works well off
himself honestly I don't know yeah I
mean it's acted I love the acting the
acting is great it says I see that like
tenure like I know he's supposed to be
12 but he looks like a 9 year old like
maybe like so I see the 9 year old body
and then it's like hey how's it going oh
my god come on guys but ya know so I'll
probably be used to it by about episode
2 of this rounds yeah so go go now I
think that's about it we'll see in the
next one
see ya